what's happening reject nation so i put
out a poll
a little bit ago saying should we talk
about evil captain america or should we
talk about
the superman and lois trailer and then i
realized
even though you got a heart out in a few
hours we could do both
and also um i got this posture corrector
that i ordered a month ago
came in the mail last night and so i was
like
well now we got to do the superman
trailer because i got a superman shirt
too and it just just to make a better
posture pose with a superman shirt on
just feels
fitting like this is what chin up means
i'm like this feels bizarre i know right
anyway who i heard great things about
this trailer and that's why i was like
yeah i think we got it we gotta cover it
yes
on your shoulders
oh how cool
[Music]
looks like they're trying to take what
was best
about the tone of something like man of
steel and expand it into a full-length
series which i honestly think's for
how big of a pill that was for some
people to swallow in terms the change in
tone and sensibility from classic
superman
it's like the perfect place to explore
something like that and i'm confident
you look so good do you get a haircut
it's viagra isn't it when you start to
slouch it like
there's like this weird indicator on
your body that's like you're slouching
yeah you're like oh we gotta get back in
line
with my not back all right yeah what's
interesting to me about this is i i
haven't been
up to date with a lot of the cw shows i
think the last thing i did see
was the final episode of arrow so that's
how behind i
am on all this i've only seen like first
half of supergirl of course seen around
the crisis on infinite earth's crossover
and i haven't seen any of that woman
even though i hear that next season is
amazing
i heard it's incredible those ratings
for the first episode of a season
ever and so i kind of expected more of
the same
when you're hearing about superman and
lois i expected something that felt more
tonally
like that this feels completely
different
and it feels cinematic that's why i
specifically cited hbo max right away
yes very man of steel approach to it i
love the idea of
you're hanging out with clark kent and
lois lane and they have kids and it
looks like this is probably from the
pilot their kids finding out what you're
really superman
and how that creates kind of a dramatic
tension between them
it has a really nuanced not like
cheesy soap opera vibe the way those cw
shows are like
i like the shows for the most part i
mean obviously i haven't kept up my love
for them to the point where i'm
religiously watching them as i once did
however
when i'm watching them i'm having a
total blast this looks like it actually
has some real edge to it i'm excited to
see what they got in store because i
think the guy who plays superman
taylor coch cochlin heckling hello
heckling however that's my best guess i
think he does a great job as clark kent
oftentimes at least with the episodes
i've like skipped around to see some of
the superman episodes and supergirl of
course seeing him on the crossover stuff
i
sort of feel like they might dumb him
down i don't know if the right word is
dumb him down
play him down a little bit so you can
really elevate up supergirl a little bit
more so for him to get his own
show here it looks great i heard a lot
of great things about this trailer and
actually seeing it i see why people were
praising it it feels
like something much more elevated versus
what we
would probably expect a lot of these cw
shows yeah i mean it actually clued me
into the idea that at least there's
gonna be
some of that oh confidence to superman
and his posture is gonna be terrific
this almost gave me two like a little
hint of not that i think it's gonna go
full on character drama but almost like
a madman vibe and some of the just like
you're hanging out at the kent house and
like they're at a barbecue or whatever
and it looked like he might give you a
chance to
sort of explore this in a slightly
different way and two
it looks like there's going to be that
character drama of like you know the way
our par or at least clark's parents
went and uh you know the family drama
that is here
like it doesn't seem like the drama is
gonna be ah being superman is
a weird conundrum for me it's more like
you know just the actual human elements
of his life are going to be explored
while he's superman i love how he's
trying to hide this identity from his
own kids though because his kids are
like teenagers at this point right yeah
i think it would be hard
no in terms of like the character drama
aspect of what you're talking about some
hints that i
i haven't read anything up on what
they're doing specifically with this
series but in terms of the character
drama enhancement clark kent did grow up
on a farm it looks like he's trying to
replicate that home life that he had
but he's not able to maintain a regular
life as much as he's trying to like
isolate himself and live on this farm
life with lois and and try to just raise
his kids it's impossible for someone
like superman to do it and more than
just
tonally and stylistically these
nourishes that we might get
that remind us of man of steel that kind
of inner conflict of whether or not to
be a hero
seems to be present here as well like he
can't seem to
hang up the cape this seems really
interesting like i this is a one minute
tease and i'm already thinking of all
the things it could be and it's really
got me engrossed and i'm you know as
somebody who's
way further on the outside of the you
know cswdc universe this actually made
me
want to check this out as soon as it
comes out what i really respect about it
is supergirl is a very
different tone from it and this version
of superman and lois was introduced in
supergirl so i thought they would just
kind of carry over that exact same
tone yeah which is a little bit more
cheesy you know like there's some cool
high-stakes scenes and i love the actors
who
melissa something or another clearly i
suck with the last names but i love the
actress who plays her also on top of
that you know superman
this version has crossed over in some of
the other cw shows as well so i think
it's a pretty
bold step to go with a darker approach
for your superman
series and have it be very like stand
out
from the other ones in terms of its tone
yeah i think this could hook a lot of
people i think a lot of people
are have been pleasantly surprised by
just how good this trailer is i'm a big
fan of the series doom patrol
i haven't seen titans yet or the other
ones that are like on dc universe so i
don't think this is gonna be like
the hard r violence series it's gonna be
on the cw
but in terms of quality television
getting a different vibe and i'm liking
it guys i'm liking it a lot anyway
guys tell me if you thought this trailer
surprised you by how much better it's
looking leave your thoughts down below
what do you think of my posture
corrector it's not an ad i wish it was
hit that like button and last but not
least
paul pj pandemic jones you are one of
the most
loyal family men who is at our patreon
page
every time i talk to you somehow we end
up talking about your family
and tending to them which just seems
like
strong superman morals and values
so you just seem like the appropriate
person to shout out
during this time and while we've
nicknamed you pandemic jones we also
mean it in the way of you will conquer
the pandemic for us mr jones i'm so
happy to have you over at our patreon
page i know 2020 has been a rough year
for a lot of people you've had your fair
share of having to deal with your own
issues related
at all however i'm hoping 2021 turns out
to be a much better
year for you as opposed to 2020 i hope
you're able to fulfill whatever
resolutions or goals you have in mind
for this year let's stay connected let's
keep talking with one another
much love to you buddy you've been a
great influence on our lives